c'est maintenant à six mois l'analyse le
jeu car biais c'est bâtir fait une
carreaux juste avant
à l'étude
[Musique]
pendant mon comme ça mais ça fait
plaisir à voir
parce qu'ils sont mignons tous les deux
ou plus lm jour là alors vous rappelez
elle elle était très très portée sur la
chose et il y avait un ou une candidate
mélodie mais le lui et adriana mais le
dis franchement elle a pas joué le jeu
assez une porte de prison la non mais
vraiment les images
franchement elle est terrible on se
demandait ce qu'elle faisait là parce
que c'est à sa ou faire des courses
c'est pareil pour elle et encore avec
des plus souriants cantal à beaumarchés
mais c'était une catastrophe c'est vrai
fait à la fin juste à s'échauffer à la
fin thermostat on ne sait pas où va la
regarder comme une claque si je te dis
je cette tendance
j'arrive vers soirée des lampes où tous
seront là qui me passionnait weiner a
story
super bizarre
jetons mari je te rappelle alors mais tu
prends ton bisous bisous quand on se
sentira que ces moments alors bon le
sourire est en option à chez elle c'est
d'ailleurs on pourrait penser que ça va
mal se passer que mais moi je plains le
garçon parce qu'elle va être autoritaire
va être terrible parce que lui il est
tout doux et oui c'est étonnant
l'émission a avancé on s'attend à un
débarras sont très logiquement et ben le
bilan selon eux contre toute attente est
positif jeudi avançait dans notre
relation récemment
apprendre la faim depuis mariage
vraiment sur la même longueur d'onde
génération de cadres et
mélodie est ce que vous souhaitez
poursuivre à découvrir
adrien et a continué et je pense que nos
listes y en encore le temps est compté
[Musique]
il faut nous laisser encore du temps
elle a fait la gueule pendant trois
semaines non c'est tout simplement une
suite qui a du caractère et qui n'a pas
envie d'embrasser un mec juste parce que
ça fait plaisir aux gens son plaisir at
elle embrasse passer à la pompe bien
belle mission tu sais pas s'il vous
plaît bien moi ça vous prouvera qu'on
dit d'eux mêmes et vous bernard ce
marché les uns même les chieuses au
final les hommes est monarchique est
très chiant
j'ai parlé à non non non non c'est alors
ce jeu franchement je ne crois pas que
les hommes aiment les avons vraiment je
suis bon je balaie les chezelles et
odieuse on plaît après ses tournées sous
combien d'appareils à mener en iran
parce que c'est ça aussi
alors qu'est ce que c'est aurait revu
ensuite la production prolongée je crois
que tant que ça se passe pas trop mal et
ils vont ils vont des épreuves donc il
ne peut plus loin dans les désaccords
mais bon la vie en attendant ça cartonne
je suis désolé on en parle tous les
vendredis donc c'est que l'émission
quand même play et intéresse je suis
désolé arrête et ensuite rien à rien de
troubler les associés sur les réseaux
sociaux
il commence à devenir des stars
d'accord avec toi et bonne nouvelle la
paix la cassine la saison prochaine a
été lancé par m ça bah ça doit être
bonne mais c'est parce que il y en a il
y aurait il y en a pour qui ça pas été
appâté top c'est mathieu mathieu avait
mal commencé
c'est mal poursuit vie et ça a mal fini
les matches et c'est compliqué mais
mathieu c'est très populaire
si rentrer dedans
et je viens de 3 dans ce cas moi je les
passe ainsi
c'est ça qui m'a vraiment poussé
j'ai envie de baisser 3 dans cette
aventure
[Musique]
je pense que je n'ai rien à regretter
rosalie mystère
louis calmer votre joie intense et
extraits oui qu'est ce qu'ils ont
entendu parler d'un certain romain des
marseillais qui aimeraient participer au
casting est ce que magali je pense que
tu devrais rester dans son créneau parce
qu'il n'ya pas de romance et que romain
est aperçue et m'a ri au premier regard
veut faire les martiens précédent les
chiffres et à des gens qui doivent
rester dans la très belle voix la raison
alors on va essayer donc toujours dans
le maine mariage vous savez quel point
le mariage ça me ça me met en joie
achats mais ça me remplit de un repli de
bonheur et c'est vrai que pour moi je
trouve que parfois c'est il ya des
belles rencontres et il se passe des
belles choses en émission n'y a pas que
des déchets contrairement à ce qu'on a
dit souvent et donc ils s'aiment
vraiment et on a une déclaration d'amour
celle là je vais la notte je n'ai pas
encore fait regarder viennent on m'a
fait mettre mes peurs puisqu'on a fait
de la plongée il m'a donné
une petite boule et j'ai bien vu qu'il y
avait une bague dedans donc du coup il
m'a présenté une pancarte avec l'écrit
oui et non et il fallait que je coche la
bonne réponse je n'ai pas hésité j'ai
coché oui
on va se remarier prochainement et on
est heureux de mon char partager leurs
nuits voilà
[Applaudissements]